[Music]
to ask you this I'm trying to put some
money together to get a better shelter
and they got fifty fifty that's too much
I can consider if I give you fifty years
to do something for me
[Music]
this is some style was going for rap
styles
it was a different passion what have you
done with my daughter
I killed her you make a habit of be
friendly girl for the significantly
younger than yourself oh my god no I was
obsessed with her boy she's a smart girl
that boy had problems so what are you
looking at
hey stop oh no it's money here love
cause my white better than the one that
I gave you
[Music]
I'll do anything can he please stay I
don't like it I just never should have
the world of favor
I have no idea what you're feeling I
can't feel anything because I can't
breathe take up all the air
I think something in you it's changed it
was like you weren't scared of anything
I don't think the water to be this big a
win if we become obsessed with
functionality
[Music]
this is the worst possible parenting I
could imagine
[Music]